tv reign has always had to choose its
words carefully
it's the only news channel in russia
that isn't pro kremlin
now the authorities are telling it what
words it can and cannot use
we continue to tell you about the war
which the military authorities call a
special military operation it's very
important for russian authorities not to
use
the words such as invasion
or war but for the moscow prosecutor's
office tv reign isn't trying hard enough
it's ordered the channel to stop
spreading what it calls false
information regarding the actions of
russian military personnel
a few hours after speaking to al jazeera
tijuan left russia with his family
tv reigns website is blocked all that's
left is this stream on youtube
state tv refers to a special operation
zone in ukraine the coverage is
concentrated on what's happening in the
battles for donetsk and lugansk now
recognized as republics by moscow
there's no mention of the attacks on
kiev or other ukrainian cities
is one of the 64 percent of russians for
whom television is their primary source
of news
do they bomb as i heard it's just the
opposite they try to somehow protect the
peaceful population as much as possible
i can't say i'd supported this from the
beginning but now i do support it that's
after the kremlin and the kremlin's
foreign channels don't refer to an
invasion russia will continue though
with
its military incursion
in arabic the headline reads russia's
military operation to protect donbass
and in french russia will continue its
offensive in ukraine
russia's communications regulator has
accused 10 outlets of falsely depicting
what it calls the military operation in
ukraine one of them's the novia gazetta
and his headline says well at least
there's some good news the word peace
hasn't been forbidden yet
bernard smith al jazeera moscow